and as we explained in our opening
monologue on friday the left continues
to claim that any opposition to their
extreme
radical socialist policies are one thing
and one thing only
that is completely totally utterly
racist that would be
d.c statehood securing the border
eliminating the legislative filibuster
funding defunding the police i don't
remember joe biden or anyone else
actually claiming that the filibuster
was a relic of
jim crow when they were filibustering
republican
legislations like 300 times like senator
tim scott's police reform bill but joe
biden the democrats they continue to
rush to judgment
demonize the police and put our most
vulnerable communities at risk by
ignoring key facts when it comes to
these officer-involved shootings and
their recklessness
in making cities less safe and with
reaction to talk specifically about what
happened in the makia bryant incident in
columbus ohio
republican senator from louisiana john
kennedy
so we aired you know there's a whole ton
of these viral videos that are out there
senator
you know of cops saying oh guys please
stop stabbing each other hang on
uh let me lebron what should i do in
this case what do you what's the proper
way to handle it
if it wasn't for the heroism of that
officer
the girl that was dressed in pink the
young woman that was pinned to the car
and the girl loaded up with that knife
about to plunge it
then thrust it into her body would have
been stabbed and
likely would have been killed and then
you saw what lebron james
did to the cop thoughts
um cops have about 60 million encounters
with americans every year when someone
is
hurt before we assume
there's this thing called asking there's
this thing called
an investigation the wilkeristas
don't want to just jump to conclusions
they want a cannonball
into them they need to get the facts
let me let me state a few propositions
that i think reflect common sense
and with respect to which most americans
other than the woker easters agree
number one most cops many of whom happen
to be black do not get up every day and
go to work
hoping for the opportunity to hurt a
person of color
number two cops are necessary
if you support defunding the police
you have tested positive for stupid
number three it is immeasurably
foolish to resist arrest
it is going to end badly even if no one
is hurt
you can't win the government has the
bomb
it's very dangerous don't resist
arrest and number four and this is just
me personally
if you are a cop and you see someone
about
to stab me i would
personally appreciate it if you would
stop them
shoot them if you have to i don't care
who they are
i don't consider that police misconduct
i consider that saving my life
i ge you you have coined the term which
i find interesting
walker easters now i gave
statistics in my opening monologue
tonight talking about
police and talking about you know the
the
the number of shootings there were 24
people shot
in chicago this weekend in new york city
50 people
shot in 46 separate incidents
uh by the way three died in chicago and
a surge of 250 percent seven day period
of time 50 people shot in new york city
senator can you name any of the people
shot this weekend
have you heard anybody report on the
names of anybody shot in new york city
or chicago this weekend
because i haven't i've looked them up
but i don't think anyone else will
likely never know any of their names
will we
why no no and
it breaks my heart but new york i think
has just edged out
chicago as the world's largest outdoor
shooting range
um i mean what
it's terrible sean it's horrible
but our post journalism in our
post-journalism
world many members of the media have a
narrative
and they only want to cherry pick
and pick instances which show cops
at their worst
i've said it before if you hate cops
just
because they're cops then uh feel free
to call a criminal call a meth head
the next time you get in trouble i mean
i just
do not accept nor do i think most
americans accept
that most cops are uh are bad people
are racist they don't get up every day
going to work hoping they can hurt
somebody most of them get up
every day and go to work and hope hope
they can themselves come back home alive
you know i have two questions for lebron
james
first question is simple and that it's
lebron if it was your daughter that was
pinned against the car
with the girl loaded with the knife
about to be thrust into your daughter
what would you want the cops to do there
and the second question i have is
related to the last question i asked you
which is
lebron do you know the names of
everybody that was shot this
weekend and why is there a priority
only on the much smaller
subset of killings and shootings that
take place in society
and that being the full focus whenever
the police are involved
and by the way many big cities now have
majority minority police forces
well sean i think everybody agrees that
police misconduct should be punished
and i agree with that police misconduct
exists but but look at the numbers let
me say it again
every year cops have encounters with 60
million americans
10 million of them are arrested in two
million cases
cops either have to use force or
threaten to use force now if if
if our friends in the media will cover
every one of those cases
and be fair about it but they are they
are cherry-picking
i don't know what the investigation is
in north carolina and how in ohio will
show
but but before we cannonball into
conclusions and
assume it's racism we ought to have an
investigation and understand it's not
representative of every case every life
matters
that would be every life that was lost
this weekend
every life people deserve safety and
security
and there shouldn't be dozens and dozens
and dozens of people shot every weekend
senator
we do know how to fix it rudy giuliani
did it you may not like his politics but
he
showed us the way thank you for being
with us hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else